[Music]
[Applause]
Tom pellicero great Insider reporter for
the NFL Network joining us on the
program
who had the best week in the NFL
that I was thinking about this this
morning so when you're doing this the
way that we do it on NFL Network and
it's just this flood of news there's so
many transactions I this morning just
started scrolling through one of the
pages on nfl.com to remember who had
signed who because you completely lose
track of everything like eventually
there'll be some point where I'm into
training camp I know in August and I'll
go that guy's on that team and then I'll
go I broke that I'm the one who reported
it and I don't even remember that
happening because then there were a
hundred other things uh in that same day
I mean I think that the teams you look
at that have kind of you know certainly
use their resources the most the Falcons
did a lot starting with the the Jesse
Bates deal uh that they did you know
they wanted to pump money into that
defense that was a huge part of it the
Bears going out and spending the way
that they did just in the opening hours
of free agency getting Tremaine Edmonds
on 18 million a year deal bringing in TJ
Edwards you know you know mattybruce's
defense runs through it's the interior
your defensive line that's the
linebackers they signed a couple of uh
of Big Time linebackers and then you
have to always have to look at the
quarterback moves too because those
ended up being the most you know over
time those end up being right or wrong
good or bad they end up being the most
impactful so the Raiders making an
investment in Jimmy Garoppolo whose
contract basically dictates he's going
to be their starter for at least two
years obviously go back to before the
start of free agency and the Derek Carr
move was significant even things like
yesterday with Gardner minshu going to
the Colts you know they're sitting there
with the number four pick but Gardner
minshu well could be their starting
quarterback in in 2023 you know last
year most of those quarterback trades
that we saw did not work out I mean Matt
Ryan Carson Wentz Russell Wilson at
least in the short term uh with Wilson
you know he did not get the Returns on
that so it's always a little bit of a
guessing game here people make big time
bets there's a reason these free agents
generally become available you never
want to build through free agency but
there were some teams with a lot of cap
space like the Bears who made some big
time moves to say nothing of the move
they made trade the number one pick and
getting DJ Moore is a part of it when
Rogers was on McAfee on Wednesday and
after he started talking about he you
know he wants to go to the Jets or plans
on going to the Jets and I kept thinking
um and we had some analysts on who said
that the Packers don't have much
leverage and I go why don't they have
leverage
they can say oh he really wants to go
there you want to bring in some of his
ex-teammates just because we don't want
him doesn't mean we don't have leverage
in what we want back from the Jets and
now you're hearing you know the Packers
they they want to have a little bit more
than maybe what we thought how do you
think this plays out when do you think
this finally plays out
so here's what I can tell you Dan based
upon what I know and there's obviously
been a lot of moving Parts I did
appreciate that Aaron Rodgers really
narrowed us to the one actual issue
which those of us who have been kind of
covering it behind the scenes have known
which is trade compensation is the only
hold up that's left in this trade so
there's a couple of important
checkpoints here just in terms of the
timeline the first one would be the NFL
draft which is still over a month away I
think that we would all love if there's
resolution right now but both sides have
their viewpoints my understanding is
they're not far apart on the
compensation but they're not close
either so the draft is an important
checkpoint not because what happens in
Aaron Rodgers
impacts who you're going to draft
because I think that we're all on the
same page that ultimately Rogers barring
something going totally sideways will be
the Jets quarterback in 2023 but it's
about the fact that once you were get
past that draft you're not talking about
2023 draft picks anymore yeah from just
a strict value standpoint you're
downgrading if you're getting a 2024
pick instead of a 2023 pick that's like
downgrade by a wrap so there's a
pressure point there potentially for the
Packers where the Jets can say hey this
is your last chance to get a premium
pick or two in the 2023 draft if you
don't do this yeah we'll keep talking
the now you're talking about picks that
don't help you this year so that's one
checkpoint if somehow you got past the
draft then the next checkpoint really
isn't until September yes there's
there'll be a pressure point prior to
start a training camp because let's face
it Aaron Rodgers has not shown up in the
past couple of years for the Packers
OTAs maybe he would show up in a new
situation in New York but there's no
guarantee of that any sidestep that
question on Pat McAfee you would like to
get him into training camps so you would
anticipate there's going to be more
conversations there but the Packers
don't have to do anything until the day
before the regular season opener because
that's when you have the trigger where
they would have to pull the trigger on
uh Aaron Rodgers option bonus so you
won't you don't want to get there
because then you're potentially paying a
guy 60 million dollars who's not really
part of your future plans but for the
Jets you don't want to get it there
because then Rogers isn't even in
training camp with the team so those are
kind of the moving Parts here along the
timeline this could you know depending
who wants to push it this absolutely
could go at least until it started
trading cap maybe into training camp
before you have a resolution I'm not
sure that's in anyone's best interest to
drag it out that long but we'll see if
the Jets aren't willing to come up to
the Packers price and if the Packers are
not willing to lower their price you're
going to have a stare down for as long
as these teams are allow it to go yeah I
hope it uh goes as follows that maybe
you give a second round pick in this
year's draft conditional first round
pick next year compared on compared to
uh you know what Aaron Rodgers does
performance you know it could be
Performance Based that maybe you're
going to get a second and a first as
opposed to two first round picks well
they're not even looking for two
first-round picks aren't asked talking
for two ones okay they that's not part
of the conversation right now right now
it is less than that it's less than the
rest of Wilson trade which was two ones
two twos and three players it's less
than the Matthew Stafford trade
depending how you do the math on that
which was two ones and Jared Goff which
then you know the Lions had to take on
his contract so it's a little bit
different calculus there Packers the
Packers price is lower than that but
certainly it's higher than what they got
for Brett Favre to the Jets uh Once Upon
a Time 15 years ago which was a fourth
round pick at that time the parallels
here Dan are fascinating to me there are
some key differences and I was on the
the beat with the Green Bay Press
Gazette in 2008 so I was living that in
Green Bay Wisconsin in the prior divorce
and I remember vividly you know far of
coming in because that one did go it
started up roughly the same time you
know to go back to that timeline it was
the Packers were wanted an answer from
Aaron Rodgers early in the off season
that happened again here with Aaron
Rodgers I've obviously farv announced
his retirement but by late March he
decided he wanted to come back Rogers
just kind of sliced that part out of the
equation and then you had very public
interviews with farv who was on Greta
Van Susteren on Fox news with with
Rogers it's on the Pat McAfee show where
you have the exchange and then you had
Ted Thompson who was a famously reticent
individual I was one of the people who
had to do some of the series of
one-on-ones with Ted on a hot June
Saturday morning because farv was saying
so much and it was swinging the public
perception and you had this went back
and forth and ultimately in that case
the Packers came down to two teams that
they were potentially going to trade
Brett Favre to was the Bucks and it was
the Jets and the Jets made their pitch
with Woody Johnson and you can hunt on
this land that we've got outside of town
there was this whole thing that went
into it and they convinced him but Fargo
wanted to go to Tampa because he would
have gotten to face the Packers that
year with Rogers again he's very much
trying to dictate this I intend to play
I intend to play with the Jets and the
Packers allowed the Jets to talk to him
even though at that time they weren't
able to agree on the compensation now
they're trying to work out that
compensation after Roger's already
declared his intentions that there's
leverage points on both sides here but
I'm just you know I it's the easy joke
Dan but you you still have to look at
Kirk Cousins has an expiring contract
and the possibilities that Aaron Rodgers
be a viking in 2024 I'm not saying that
I'm not speculating that I'm not
reporting that don't don't
hypothetically hypothetically and you
know frankly you got two guys who are
you know in both cases kind of made
clear they're doing this at least partly
out of spite with farv it was very much
he wanted to play again because the
Packers said he was done and they tried
to make him stay retired and then he
ends up going to the Vikings with Rogers
he said he's 90 retired when he goes
into the darkness he comes out some
other players are telling him that they
want to get rid of you and he decides
you know what I want to play for the
Jets it's as as one of my former
colleagues at the Presque is that said
to me recently these guys all end up
being the same guy it never ends well
you can say Roger's learned all the
lessons from farm and he did there were
a lot of things that Aaron took with him
throughout his career in Green Bay and
they're both phenomenal players and fun
guys to cover but in the end if you
still have a guy who wants to play and
he feels like he's not wanted there's no
way for that to end cleanly for
everybody involved Tom pellicero NFL
Network Insider Before I Let You Go
Lamar Jackson had a tweet where he
congratulated Orlando Brown Jr for
getting the contract with the Bengals
then he says when this is all said and
done I feel bad for the rest of the 31.
the other 31 teams what's he saying in
this tweet
seems like Lamar and I did not see that
tweet but certainly seems like that's
the message of if you're not the team
that gets me you're going to regret it
it still remains to be seen Dan and and
I know that there's a lot of people who
have brought up collusion have even
suggested racism have suggested a
variety of different reasons why
nobody's willing to just go out you know
people say he's just sitting there Lamar
Jackson MVP is just sitting there think
of it this way and I had a lot of
conversations yesterday in particular
with people with different teams who
potentially could be in that market and
it's not to say and in no way am I
saying nobody should go out and try to
get one of the dynamic players within
the NFL but it has to be a specific
situation there are a number of teams
you can easily cross off of the 32. you
can cross off 20 teams just by going
through and saying who has a Young
quarterback already that they're going
to pay or who has a bunch of money tied
up in a veteran quarterback there's
about 20 teams you can cross right off
the list so now you're down to about a
dozen of them you've got teams that
either may have a quarterback who
they're going with for now or they have
some money invested there's probably a
half dozen of those who you can kind of
say it's probably not going to happen
there now you're down to a half dozen of
them and you need to figure out it's not
just go get the quarterback this isn't
fantasy football it's not mad it's real
life where there's contracts and there's
value and there's scheme so if you're
going to go after Lamar Jackson
if you're going to evaluate this and
certainly there's teams that have you
need to be willing to give up the two
first-round picks
to pay him what he wants which he has
not backed off of which is a fully
guaranteed contract it's going to be in
the neighborhood of 50 million dollars a
year which is about 25 percent of your
salary cap you're doing that with a
player who you're going to need to
change your scheme to change at least
some of your personnel to make it go
and he's a player whose Mobility has
always been a big part of his game
and he suffered consecutive lower body
injuries
that have ended his season
speed Mobility those are by definition
depreciating Assets in other words those
injuries are something real to consider
the teams absolutely look at it's not to
say that means Lamar Jackson's never
going to be MVP caliber Lamar Jackson
again I think we agree Dan when you
watch him when he's healthy when he's on
field he's pretty good he's pretty fun
to watch but also you know you can cite
the the passing efficiency and the
explosive plays well big part of the
reason he has that is because when the
quarterback is a run threat it changes
the numbers on the defense you have to
account for the quarterback as a runner
it changes how defenses can play you're
going to see more specific types of
coverages and the picture is going to be
clearer on the back end where you're
going to have those opportunities Lamar
absolutely has gotten better as a passer
he's absolutely an unbelievably Dynamic
Runner but are you willing to make that
type of investment and remember too you
do have limited resources in terms of
building your team part of the reason
you've seen this shift toward people
wanting more and more to build around a
Young quarterback is the salary cap it's
cash it's resources it's the fact that
when you're not paying 50 million
dollars a year for a quarterback which
is soon going to be the going rate now
we'll be talking about the first 60
million dollar quarterback with the way
the Cap's going
that's money you're not spending
to put people around him if you're the
Bears and you have Justin fields and you
might say well Lamar's right now a more
polished passer and he's as Dynamic of a
runner we can get him but then that's 50
million dollars or 45 million dollars
that we don't have to spend on other
things we have Justin Fields right now
on a rookie contract those are all the
things you have to evaluate here in
terms of the value of the position in
terms of the value of the player and
that's not a slight to Lamar and that's
not collusion and that's not racism it's
the reality of team building in the
modern NFL where you're going to be
hard-pressed to find teams that have had
a great deal of success after midi
committing 20 plus of their salary cap
to a single player the Chiefs are doing
it with Patrick Mahomes on a unique deal
to pay them 60 million dollars over the
first three years and it's a long long
term contract that gives them a lot of
flexibility and that was the intention
when he did that contract most
quarterback contracts are not like that
there is a cap and a cash impact on you
that's going to influence things in
terms of Lamar action and there's some
fascinating conversations that can be
had particularly if in the coming weeks
here as you're seeing these chairs get
filled around the league Lamar does not
have an offer sheet then your attention
starts to be turned to what does he do
with a 32 million dollar franchise tag
does he go back to Baltimore he
potentially could stay away all the way
until I believe it's week 10 that he can
still sign an offer sheet with the team
and then show up at that point that
would seem for a guy who played for 1.7
in 2021 and 23 million I believe it was
in 2022 an odd strategy to suddenly
start giving up all those millions of
dollars but at the same time if Lamar
had an agent that agent would have
advised him two years ago you're not
stepping on the field for 2021 at 1.7
million he's already given up tens of
millions of dollars and he's got to
evaluate now do you continue to go down
that path or do you take the best offer
you can possibly get even if it's not
fully guaranteed whether that's from the
Ravens who have been trying for a couple
of years or pretend someone else
have a great weekend Tom thank you we
appreciate your time always a pleasure
that's Tom pellicero he works for NFL
Network